y para volver a repasar un poco la
historia de la monarquía británica
porque Antes nos hemos quedado a medias
prioridad al directo porque ya estaba
empezando esa ceremonia volvemos a tener
en el estudio Álvaro Cordero qué tal qué
tal están compañeros Gracias Álvaro
Bueno pues retomemos entonces estábamos
viendo a lo largo de esta línea de
tiempo ese proceso de el cambio hacia el
modelo parlamentario cómo lo vivió
entonces la monarquía como sobrevivió a
esto Sí bueno habíamos comentado que la
monarquía en Reino Unido ya existe desde
prácticamente 12 siglos y que había
vivido una serie de procesos que
unificadores que habían hecho que esta
monarquía fuese fuese avanzando y
ganando cada vez más importancia y más
notoriedad dentro de dentro de Europa
habíamos hablado de los tutor que es una
una dinastía de las más importantes que
consiguió
que la iglesia anglicana se extinguiera
de la Iglesia Católica Donde había
estado Inglaterra durante prácticamente
mil años y bueno obviamente tuvo
repercusiones en toda Europa porque esta
decisión que en un principio fue
política al final hizo que y no era y no
era teológica al final hizo que otros
países lógicamente reaccionaran sobre
todo el entorno de Roma
esta esta decisión de Enrique VIII lo
que lo que hizo es que El Monarca
británico no solamente fuese el máximo
exponente político de esa nación sino
que fuese el religioso como ya hemos
comentado anteriormente en este en este
especial y bueno este proceso de
crecimiento de la monarquía británica
siguió un paso bastante fuerte también
con la siguiente gran monarca que se
considera la primera gran reina de Reino
Unido que fue Isabel Isabel I consolidó
lo que era ya el incipiente Imperio
británico y desde luego mantuvo una
campaña muy exitosa contra la que
entonces era la potencia global que era
el Imperio español el Imperio español no
consiguió doblegar a Inglaterra e
Inglaterra consiguió aumentar su
presencia en América y luego
progresivamente en otros continentes hay
que tener en cuenta compañeros que
cuando hablamos de esa monarquía no
tiene nada que ver esa monarquía de esos
siglos con la actual
estas monarquías están regidas por un
sistema absolutista en el que el rey
tenía el total control sobre la política
sobre la economía sobre las relaciones
internacionales de esa época y desde
luego estaba muy lejos de la monarquía
parlamentaria democrática que tenemos en
la actualidad exactamente precisamente
esto lo quería preguntar Álvaro cómo
hizo la monarquía británica para
adaptarse al sistema parlamentario Bueno
pues el proceso vino a partir del año
1689 la conocida como Revolución
gloriosa que depuso al entonces Rey
Jacobo II y trajo a la dinastía Orange
al poder básicamente la monarquía
británica fue pionera en Europa en este
sentido porque hasta entonces
otras monarquías como la francesa o la
española como les comentaba reinaba el
absolutismo este este proceso hacia el
parlamentarismo No fue fácil Durante los
siguientes siglos hubo algunos reyes que
se opusieron A este paso al parlamento
al parlamentarismo y a ceder control al
parlamento y Bueno aquí es donde ya
empiezan a surgir lo que se conocen como
los partidos políticos primarios que
eran los tories conservadores más
favorables a que tuviese poder el rey y
los wix o liberales más favorables a que
el parlamento tuviese ese control sobre
el rey otro momento importante la
historia de este país cuando se
desarticula el Imperio británico la casa
Real Como sobrevive a esto Cómo se
mantiene siendo una institución sólida
una vez el Imperio británico terminó
obviamente no fue fácil fue un proceso
de varias décadas hay que recordar que
durante el reinado de Victoria primera
de Victoria primera el Imperio británico
prácticamente alcanzó su apogeo en del
mundo era la primera potencia global
pero este proceso se empieza a dar sobre
todo a partir del inicio del siglo 20
hay que recordar que en Europa se
vivieron dos guerras mundiales Que
obviamente debilitaron de forma
sustancial a Reino Unido y además eso
sumado al crecimiento exponencial de
Estados Unidos en aquella época hicieron
que el Imperio británico perdiera poder
durante varias décadas seguidas pero a
diferencia de otras potencias coloniales
europeas Lo cierto es que el Imperio
británico consiguió mantener una
relación bastante positiva con muchas de
estas colonias Por qué Porque tiempo
antes de que estas colonias se
independizaran de forma definitiva desde
Londres Se garantizó que estos
territorios pudieran ser pudieran ser
autogobernados por personas de allá
descendientes de británicos y en muchos
casos sobre todo blancos en especial
Australia Nueva Zelanda o Canadá de
hecho estas naciones siguen teniendo al
Rey Carlos III actualmente como jefe del
estado y como como monarca principal de
estos territorios
esta este tipo de desarrollo fue una
forma incipiente de lo que luego sería
la commonwells que básicamente es el
gran éxito de Isabel II como monarca en
cuestión de relaciones internacionales
el fortalecimiento de una de una
organización de una mancomunidad que
consiguió mantener al rey como cabeza de
esa desorganización y e incluir en ella
a la gran mayoría de las antiguas
colonias británicas pertenecieran O no
todavía a esa Corona británica Porque
por ejemplo hay repúblicas como como es
el caso de la India o Sudáfrica dentro
de commonwell y bueno Isabel II durante
las primeras décadas de su reinado
consiguió fomentar de una forma bastante
positiva para los intereses de Reino
Unido esto como está como un Wells que
actualmente sigue sigue vigente Es
verdad que está todavía en
cuestionamiento con respecto a cuál va a
ser el papel de Carlos III en ella pero
Lo cierto es que es uno de sus grandes
éxitos en el siglo XX y precisamente
Álvaro no una de las pocas ocasiones en
las que Isabel II se mojó mínimamente
públicamente en temas de política fue a
la hora de
insistir en que entonces marcar el
tácher no se uniera a otros países de la
común West en imponer sanciones a
Sudáfrica por el apart precisamente y
cambiando un poco la tónica de esta
Crónica le quiero pedir unos detalles
históricos sobre el lugar donde se ha
celebrado esta ceremonia y donde se
coronan los reyes de Inglaterra del
Reino Unido desde
recibe este tipo de eventos desde el año
1066 como tú decías Rosa pero en un
principio estaba día se construyó bajo
el orden católico porque todavía no
había habido esa decisión de la de la
iglesia
americana Lo cierto es que toma Más
relevancia Una vez que se produce esa
decisión a partir del reinado de Enrique
VIII porque básicamente se convierte en
el en el centro religioso más importante
dentro de esta corriente anglicana
dentro de ella se han vivido varios
varios matrimonios reales 16 en concreto
se han enterrado a la mayoría de Los
Monarcas por supuesto las coronaciones y
además es un punto muy importante dentro
de la política y la historia británica
ya que también hay grandes personajes de
la historia de este país enterrados en
esta abadía como ocho primeros mil
primeros ministros del Reino Unido o
personas tan importantes como Charles
Darwin o Stephen hawkings Álvaro pues
muchas gracias por todo este contexto
histórico de lo que significa estos
momentos de la historia del Reino Unido
para la continuación de lo que ha sido
la casa real de Windsor allí en este
país Muchas gracias
por haber estado aquí con nosotros en el
estudio